今日は
皆さんに
ご報告がございます
今年の目標
もう一個決めよう。
という話をしてたんですけども
決まりました。今年の目標は
これからは
お菓子を食べません！
（はじめしゃちょーの泣き声）
あの
色々訳があるんですよ。
僕はお菓子大好きなんですよ。
動画とか関係なく
日常的にお菓子を食うんですよ！
お風呂入る時も、
寝る前も
ゲームしてる時も
動画編集する時も
いつでもお菓子を食べてきたんですよ！！
（はじめしゃちょーの泣き声と嘔吐）
僕は気付いてしまったんです。
この歳になって
これ以上お菓子を食べると体に悪いんですよ！
（はじめしゃちょーの叫び声）
ネットでですねいろいろ調べたわけですよ。
お菓子、食べない、効果、とか。
チョコレートとも食べ過ぎてもうなんかニキビとかができてるんですよ。
お肌をキレイにしたいと思ったらチョコを食べないのが根本的解決とかさ
チョコを食べない生活を3年してる方がいたんですけども
めちゃくちゃ肌がキレイになったとか言ってて
お肌がキレイになりたい！
お肌の乾燥が治るみたいです。
太らなくなるんですよ。
（はじめしゃちょーの叫び声）
（小声で）ちょっと太りたかった
僕が実家にいた時はお菓子を食べ過ぎてて夜ご飯が食べれなかったって事があってよく怒られてたんすよ。
すごいカロリーが高い。
高い。どれもとても高い。
でその、お腹が空いた時に最初に食べるもの吸収率ってすごい高いんで、
もしおなかが空いてるときにお菓子とかを食べると、
そのお菓子の油とか砂糖とかね、
というのが一番吸収される。それはとても
体に良くないんです。
マジ僕はですね
今年はちょっとおかしを食べないで
おいしいご飯、しっかりした食べ物をしっかり食べて、しっかり栄養をとって、きっちりとした食生活を、まず見直そうかと思います。
（はじめしゃちょーが机を叩く）
なんでだよ！！
自分で決めたんだった…
最近じいちゃんが糖尿病になったんで
僕も糖尿病になるかもしれないんすよ
（はじめしゃちょーの叫び声）
ほんとにヤバいんすよ、でも。
お菓子食べ過ぎると。
あ、ジュースも飲まないっす。
もうジュースも飲みません。
（はじめしゃちょーの叫び声）
もうジュースも飲まない。
ジュースの方が下手したら砂糖の量が多いかもしれないので、
ジュース、お菓子は、この動画をもちまして
今年は、食べません！
やむを得ない場合は食べますけど。
やむを得ない場合は食べますよ。
もしセイキンさんがお土産にお菓子を持ってきて、
「これを食わねぇと殺すぞ」と言われると
食べますよ！
それ以外に、僕が自らお菓子を食べるようなマネはしませんし、
もう食べません。今年は。
その代わり美味しいご飯を食べれば良いんです。
美味しくて、健康的で、体に良いご飯を、
お腹ペコペコの時に食べるのが、大事だと思うんですよ。
（はじめしゃちょーのすすり泣き）
メリットとしては！
ダイエットに繋がる
お肌が綺麗になる
食生活が良くなる
多分、メリットは大きいんですよ。
けど、そのb…………（発狂）
いいんですよ、いいんです。
自分には甘かった、俺は。
いつでも好きな時に甘いもの食ってさ…！
甘々な生活をしてたわけですよ、俺は！
わあぁぁぁぁ………！（発狂）
ここにあるお菓子は…
全部…
食べまぁーす。
ここには、僕の好きなお菓子を、全部買ってきました。
これを食べれたら、もう僕は、
これを持ちましてお菓子を食べなくなります。
そこの、お肌ボロボロの人！
デブ！
ニキビたくさんある人！
そういうのは全部ねぇ、全部お菓子が原因なんすよ！
そう思おうよ！
そうなんだよ！
なぁ！
お菓子が全ての根源だよ。美味しいよ。
美味しくてたまんねぇよ！
幸せな気持ちにもなるさ！
でもなぁ、お前たち覚えとけ。
それ相応の代価を払ってるんだぞ、
なぁ！
ということなんだよ。
今しかないんすよ、変えるのは。
人生変えるのは今しかないんすよ！
中途半端な覚悟でやってるわけじゃないんすよ。
マジな覚悟で、僕ちょっと今回決めてるんで、
もし、お菓子を食べるようなマネがこの先あったら…
坊主にします！
うん。絶対坊主にする。
セイキンさんがもし「お菓子食わねぇと殺すぞ」みたいな場面になると食べますけど、
第三者が絡んでいない状態で、
僕はお菓子を断固として食べません。
美味しいご飯を食べます。
今後の僕を、見守っていて下さい。
マジで食べませんから。
というわけで、今日の動画では、最後にお菓子を食べます。
いただきます。
お前たちのその甘さ、
お菓子っていうのは人を幸せにするんだよ。
何度助けられたことか。
辛い時もあったし、
悲しい時もあった。
けどお前らを食べるとな、
俺は頑張れたんだよ。ここまで。
お菓子って言うのは、人を幸せにするんすよ。心からね。
でもそれだけじゃどうしょうもない時が来るんすよ。
それが今なんです。
今しかないんすよ。
僕は
お菓子たちを乗り越えて、
もっとスゲー奴になるんで。
《俺は、
たくさんのお菓子を
食べて食べて食べまくった。
そう、
こいつらの味を、
忘れないように、
一つ一つ、
大切に、
味わったんだ。》
[マサキ] 　もしもしー
[はじめしゃちょー]　もしもし、マサキ、お菓子欲しい？
[マサキ]　うん。
[はじめしゃちょー]　食べに来ていいよ。
「もうお菓子食べません 」　終